Wow profits no man alive needs this much
stuff walking in it was shocking
now van T's oil paintings silverware
does it not
I mean frustrate you that we're sat with
all this and yet we can't pay our staff
properly there's someone I'd like you to
meet she's the head auctioneer at
Bonhams in Boston
Amy good morning good morning Gordon
nice to see goron great to see otherwise
thank you so much for coming and we're
in the [ __ ] basically and this stuff
needs to go we need to raise as much
money as possible so what's the best
price we can get for all this stuff what
you have here doesn't read as a
collection to me it's kind of an
accumulation a lot of copies of things
or if they are of the period that
they're supposed to be there's some
condition issues
[Music]
I would say about 25,000 say that good
25,000 $25,000 all this all this amy's
opinion on our are things was shocking
and I can't really believe that on the
painting the painting is a copy and not
a good one I'm afraid how much that work
I can't imagine what someone would pay
for it it's really very low value Wow
Robert I thought you said it was
expensive 18th century
well it's dated and dated 17 it is but
it's not actually of that period at all
I'm sorry did you know that was a copy I
did not know that that was a company
lots of copies reproductions
reproductions we're hoping in the
ballpark of three to four hundred
thousand 25 grand for everything yeah
that won't even get us through the next
five weeks even all this amazing
silverware I put $100 on everything on
this table hundred dollars what about
this first period this Sheffield yeah
its plate what about this 175 bucks
those are Barkov candlesticks they just
don't bring very much at auction I'm
afraid is this the current election that
you'd be willing to sell at Bonhams will
you take the whole lot no we wouldn't
Wow we would have to say no
right folks like this why do I have to
ask weekly for fish to be eyes down do
not take this sign down do not take my
pens by your own if you use this through
replace it or buy a new one with your
paycheck bloody hell
Charmin can definitely have issues let's
see how if you eat these cookies take
one to your next job interview I mean my
god I'm surprised anyone still [ __ ]
works here this guy is incredible this
is insane
I can't believe Ken is so
passive-aggressive with his staff I need
to talk to him and find out what the
hell is going on I come across all these
little notes about don't take this if
you do take it your next interview you
tell me what's going on I don't like
being taking advantage of I have some
hard times with things that they do then
why are you talking to them why are you
leading them why are you motivating them
why aren't you getting close to them the
secret of any good management's about
communication understanding and putting
yourself on their level maybe I look at
it as they should be on my level who
you're kidding
hello welcome nice to meet you always
good to see you too Gordon first name is
Melissa Melissa good morning how are you
Lisa croc Lisa nice to see you got no
very happy I do I
it's my resting face Wow yes
welcome to the Vienna so happy to be
here well I'm sure the cat food cat got
run over I see
and you gotta stuffs probably right
actually better to see you now right I'm
yeah love the tie by the way
thank you everyone wears this wow how
much are the outfits about 300 $400 $300
Everage you know they get their own I
mean there are their own dresses you
know
oh you buy your own uniforms yeah stop
heads we do oh they haven't for many
years and it reminds them to not gain
weight for me a sure thing okay you
can't possibly mess up a soft-boiled egg
can he okay what boiled egg what I'm
just like going Wow
[Music]
my Bionic cup [ __ ] hells bells I was
wrong
is this really happening he can't even
boil a [ __ ] egg [ __ ] thing's still
got feathers on it
[Music]
oh wow oh wow looking moldy tortillas
there should not be [ __ ] any moldy
[ __ ] food plugin horrible so when was
this nice not Saturday no I need any
smell that ain't nataas and I know that
this terrible just be [ __ ] ashamed
okay okay no it's not okay what is that
to be taught a black mole what's that
supposed to be Thai chili marinade my
chili marinade roundup has been used in
a while the sauces was from a chef that
had been there like in 2006 or 7 or
something is it exactly the same way as
you run this [ __ ] hotel you don't
give a [ __ ] I gave you [ __ ] I give a
[ __ ] this is your dream of running a
hotel Manning up like [ __ ] owners we
what we are this is [ __ ] unacceptable
and it's not gonna happen anymore
have you checked out because you should
do it take these two [ __ ] he's not
checked out he's talked checked out an
ID obviously I need to pay more
attention and do better on my job how
many of you can run a [ __ ] business
I ever see three CEOs three general
managers Oh three [ __ ] Executive
Chefs
ah it's like don't do run dice are you
guys reading the [ __ ] owners to story
[ __ ] off